Gerade haben wir hier noch seine theorie erklärt dass das universum eigentlich mit dem urknall keinen anfang hat sondern quasi
Wie die erdkugel nur in vielen dimensionen eine kugel ist ohne anfang und ende
Eine seiner bahnbrechenden theorien stephen hawking ist tot und ich habe einige stunden gebraucht um diese nachricht zu verdauen
deswegen kommt das video heute etwas später
Heute morgen starb der astrophysiker in cambridge alles über stephen hawking und warum man uns fehlen wird jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Das war sein schicksal eigentlich sollte stephen hawking schon viel früher sterben so seiner ärzte damals 1963 bekam er die diagnose
Hls amyotrophe lateralsklerose
Eigentlich hätte
Er spätestens fünf jahre später also 1968 sterben sollen er hat den tod 50 jahre hinausgezögert
Und in dieser zeit veröffentlicht der absolut und bahnbrechende arbeiten was hat 64 machte
er die unglaubliche voraussage dass schwarze löcher auch wieder verschwinden
Das war eine absolute sensation bis dahin wurde das für absolut unmöglich gehalten nach ihm wurde dann auch die strahlung benannt die das verursacht
die hawking strahlung
dadurch entstand aber ein dilemma
informationen würden durch diesen vorgang unwiederbringlich verloren gehen 2004
korrigierte sich hawking und konnte das dilemma lösen seine these die informationen würden nicht verschwinden sondern nur
unlesbar wie in einem verbrannten buch dann begründete
er den urknall mathematisch er fand heraus dass sich die singularitäten in schwarzen löchern
also
der vermutete kritik ritze kleine punkt in der mitte jeden schwarzen loches
genauso verhalten wie der beginn des universums der urknall eine singularität
Stand demnach am anfang aber und das ist eine wirklich umwerfende these das ist gar nicht der anfang
im eigentlichen sinne hawking ist das universum nämlich eine kugel mit der zeit eine 4
dimensionale kugel der urknall ist dabei
Am nordpol aber der ist wie bei uns kein ende sondern nur ein punkt auf der oberfläche
Er geht davon aus damit auch bewiesen zu haben dass es keinen gott braucht denn das universum war schon immer da
Und wird es auch immer sein und zeit wie wir menschen sie empfinden gibt es eigentlich so gar nicht der tod von stephen hawking
Hat etwas und rüstig ist es geht ein absolut unglaublicher denker
Den es so nicht noch einmal gibt und er selbst glaubt auch nicht an gott und irgendetwas
Das nach dem tod kommt niemand wird seine stelle einnehmen können
Im guardian wurde hawking zum tod befragt und antwortete ich sehe das gehirn als ein computer der die arbeit
Einstellt wird seine komponenten versagen es gibt keinen himmel für kaputte computer dass es ein märchen für menschen die sich vor der dunkelheit
fürchten hoffen wir mal dass sich hawking da vielleicht mal der anlass gebietet heute keine and card zu machen
rest in peace stephen hawking lief long and prosper